i thought it threw it just at the
thoughts
it's happening y'all it's happening
jackson
and april aka japal are together again
we're gonna be able to see this reunion
tonight on grey's anatomy on abc this is
your return
after leaving three seasons ago working
with jessie
he's so easy it's so easy to work with
him
and it was honestly like the most
delightful homecoming
are we going to see you stick around for
the rest of the season it's just this
one episode
you know when people ask is the door
closed and will you ever come back i'm
like
anybody can come back apparently you can
show up on the beach
right after you're dead did you all come
back because maybe you feel like this is
gonna be the last season
well you know when the writers called me
to
to pitch the idea and i asked like is
this the last season they're like we
don't know
but we're gonna give it all we got as
excited as we are about grey's anatomy
we're all so excited about your new show
yeah yes indeed cool summer airing
tuesday nights on freeform
this was the most watched debut in
freeform's history right
yes i think people are really invested
in both of these two leading ladies you
know olivia holt and kiera aurelia and
you
feel and empathize with both of them but
you continue to get
pieces of information that make you go
somebody's got to be lying right wait a
minute
it's happening i hope you rot in hell
and it's set in the 90s and the 90s it's
set in the night come on now
and then you have the ep of the show
which is jessica biel you know i
i love her but i've never met her i know
and jessica
i know i know because of kovid oh you
know she was
she was producing from a distance
jessica i can't wait to meet you